bonjour michel est clair bonjour deux
mois après ce qui vous est arrivé on a
tout simplement cette première question
envie de savoir tout simplement comment
vous allez aujourd'hui ça va je je me
suis fait opérer qu'au mois de décembre
du tendon au biceps gauche on était
resté à l'époque sur 17 était de six
jours finalement on est aujourd'hui
ba aujourd'hui si vous voulez j'attends
j'attends les délais les résultats de
désuet
il faut savoir si voilà c'est que quand
gg quand j'ai été entendu par le médecin
des yeux j'ai qui il était resté assis
devant moi je me souviens très bien de
cette scène est assis devant moi et je
racontais moi tout ce que j'avais subi
je vais difficilement je me souviens
montrer mon bras vous avez un énorme
bleus je vais montrer je lui ai dit je
comprends pas j'ai des douleurs je vais
demander c'est je pouvais pas avoir une
sorte de dérogation ce que je pouvais
plus mettre les menottes dans le dos
tout ça m'a été refusé mais je n'ai pas
tenu rigueur parce que je me disais que
c'était la loi et que le problème
puisque j'avais jamais vraiment très mal
après avoir accumulé les laisser journée
tu étais et j'ai lu que les policiers on
avait 5
j'étais un peu choqué ça prouve au
médecin il a pas il n'a pas pris en
compte la
fort de vos blessures ba 112 et sûr pour
moi le médecin déjà il ne m'a pas
occulter donc ça a été difficile de
faire un diagnostic
moi j'ai pour vous dire la vérité j'ai
pris ça pour de la pudeur au départ mais
bon vu le résultat comme tout le monde
en finale et ce qui se passe d'un point
de vue physique mais aussi le côté
psychologique justement comment il est
des choses
aujourd'hui psychologiquement je savais
pas que j'allais tout c'est dur je me
fais des jeux peu fédé là dessus pour
que vraiment sortir
c'est pas quelque chose j'ai vraiment du
mal à en discuter parce que lui par
pudeur j'ai grandi comme ça mais c'était
je suis pas pressé au quotidien comment
ça se passe ça veut dire et encore des
moments du passé qui reviennent de ce
qui s'est passé ce soir là
très honnêtement il n'ya plus j'ai pu de
plus trop de 2,2 mon cauchemar je
faisais beaucoup au début
après je pense que je suis bien entouré
on met beaucoup j'ai mes amis qui sont
là chez d'un soutien je pensais même pas
qu'elle ait autant de tracteurs n'était
en france qu'est ce que vous voulez dire
aujourd'hui à toutes ces personnes qui
se sont mobilisées dans un premier temps
remercie alors je dois dire merci parce
que parce que leur soutien et il me
permet de mettre un pied devant l'autre
tous les jours au delà des messages de
soutien il ya aussi ont près des des
réactions politiques
quelques jours après il ya le président
de la république et même à conques a
publié une une la sur twitter
en parlant même de honte notamment
qu'est ce que ça vous a suscité vous
comme comme réaction il a eu des mots
forts
sa réponse était assez rapide
le président est allé chercher à vous à
vous rencontrer le ministre de
l'intérieur une liste de l'intérieur je
ne crois pas présent république oui mais
pour l'instant ça s'est pas concrétisé
non je pense que d'autres priorités
quand on entre le terme justement que
les policiers ont déconné c'est est-ce
qu'elle est utilisée par ailleurs
darmanin déconner jurés dire aux
policiers aux gendarmes que moi je les
soutiens sans faille
mais le contrepartie de ce soutien c'est
évidemment l'exigence du milieu
intérieur pour le respect absolu de la
loi et à la déontologie
lorsqu'à des gens qui déconne ils
doivent quitter l'uniforme de la
république ils doivent être sanctionnés
ils doivent quitter ce travail ils
doivent être punis par la justice
je pas compris j'ai pas que j'avais pas
compris je pense aux ennemis moi je n'ai
pas compris c'est du génie c'est mollahs
jeu ok basse après ça va peut-être avec
tout le réseau j'ai pas compris moi
personnellement ou cnca réforme de
blessures sont là supplémentaires
psychologique de se dire on ne met pas
les bons termes sur ce que moi j'ai vécu
je décris comme un manque de respect
mois mais un après chacun est libre de
deux mois en tout cas personnellement je
les ai je la ressentais comme ça je m'en
foutiste co2 heureusement qu' il y avait
eu d'autres mots d'autres
personnalité ou ou ou d'autres députés
ou d'autres pas heureusement qu'il y
avait eu il y avait une autre personne
qui disait autre chose qui accompagnait
son nom sont là parce que j'avais lu
j'ai pu lire autre chose derrière il ya
aussi le point concernant la faire on
rappelle qu'il ya quatre policiers qui
ont été mis en examen il y en a deux qui
étaient en prison
ils ont finalement été libérés peu de
temps avant les fêtes de fin d'année
comment vous avez vécu ces
rebondissements judiciaires entre le
fait qu'ils aillent en prison au début
qu'ils soient finalement libéré quelques
semaines plus tard
honnêtement j'ai mal vécu je sais mais
avec eux parce que tout le monde sait où
je serais moi si je n'avais pas toutes
ces vidéos jeux jeux
c'est quelque chose que je ne comprends
pas je n'arrive pas à comprendre comment
j'arrive je n'arrive pas à comprendre
tous les faits afin d'aider les toutes
les preuves en vidéo sont là j'ai
l'impression qu'elle voit d'avoir en
tout cas je parle de mon affaire y avoir
plein de choses accablantes qu'il ne
laisse pas de trop de place aux a
quelques doutes que ce soit et mais qu'
ils peuvent
c'est pas je crois que je comprends pas
j'ai l'impression que que l'état veille
sur cette bienveillance sûr c'est sur
ces trois personnes là je suis pas sûr
que tu pas sûr que dans dans des
circonstances similaires d'autres genres
et sûrs ce même traitement
il ya l'importance de la vidéo justement
ce que vous évoquez à l'instant de dire
que s'il est passé vidéo ça aurait pu
être l'inversé
ce serait vous qui serait en prison
aujourd'hui une certitude je pense que
personne n'en doute de sa un peu une
vidéo celle des voisins on hammam avait
ma seule voix je sais ne j'ai pas
l'impression que ma voix
aurait eu le même poids que celles de
ces personnes là moi j'ai la chance
d'avoir eu des vidéos il ya plein de
gens qui essaient oubliez tout ça ces
gens là au bout d'un moment quand je
dors quand j'ai obligé tout ce peut-être
même les jours où c'était cette
agression mais arrivé peut-être même que
quelqu'un d'autre avec la même chose
sans caméra sans répit cette personne là
et aujourd'hui on leur en prison il est
question ici d les propos qu'ont pu
tenir ces policiers jour là les propos
que vous avez dit comme étant raciste et
a insulté de sale [__]
moi franchement aujourd'hui ce jeu je ne
sais pas trop quoi dire je sais pas
contredire à ça parce que parce que ça
me choque encore aujourd'hui non non
vous apprenez la libération de ces
policiers voilà on est peu de temps
avant noël
c'est tout juste un mois après ce que
vous avez vécu quand vous apprenez cette
information là on vous dit
c'est une injustice
[Musique]
vous savez moi je souhaite la présence
de personnes en plus pas une personne
comme très joueurs mais je dois avouer
que demanderont dans ce cas précis là il
était en prison en bas fall est resté en
fait vous devriez être encore
aujourd'hui sa place a été non parce que
je en fait je comprends je comprends
totalement pourquoi il pourrait être
libéré aujourd'hui donc je comprends
mieux pourquoi mais moi ce que je sais
c'est que moi j'aurais pas été libérés a
et c'est ce qui me dérange c'est que
yahia d'iliad et des hommes il ya des
vidéos qui sont on peut pour pour paul
et au final c'est par mon essai de deux
ça se passe pas comme c'est pas mal
c'est parce qu'il n'ya pas d'égalité en
fait tenu deux poids deux mesures quand
mais aussi la justice justement
qu'est-ce que vous en attendez vous
aujourd'hui je les fais j'ai été
tabassée à l'intérieur et à l'extérieur
de mon studio et il ya la question
raciale et e
on est né les faux procès verbaux et les
faux procès verbaux il aurait envoyé en
prison
c'est une double peine en fait je me
fait tabasser dit menthe et je me
retrouve en prison s'il veut pas me
vidéo ça c'est une réalité et je pense
que c'est bien de de le reconnaître
aujourd'hui tout ce que je demande c'est
que c'est que la vérité soit faite
du coup encore une fois je je moi
j'écoute je fais confiance à la justice
une confiance totale en la justice
aujourd'hui j'espère n'ai pas changé
d'avis et la question justement quand on
quand on parle des les policiers en
général et au moment de la révélation de
la faire il ya certains syndicats de
police qui sur les réseaux sociaux sur
des plateaux télé où justement cherché à
vous ramener à votre passé judiciaire
à vous de passer loin de la sphère loin
de ce qui s'est passé ce jour là avec le
recul aujourd'hui ça me suis quoi comme
réaction de voir que les syndicats ont
voulu justement mettre ça sur le tapis
ce qui était pas en lien avec les faits
ce soir là ce qu'on va choquer quand
j'ai vu ça ça m'a choqué de voir comment
comment ils agissent
comment ils essayent de distordre la
réalité en faisant presque deux mois une
caricature moi j'ai finalement j'ai
trouvé ça grotesque après mai
au moins ce qu'on m'a permis de
comprendre comment ils ont réussi à des
idées mais d'autres personnes qui
étaient qui était pourtant des victimes
à la base vous avez aussi reçu des
messages de soutien de la part de
policiers
c'est le cas notamment de à
l'information qui est policier on va le
voir dans cet extrait qu'on va pouvoir
écouter je suis pro forces de l'ordre je
défende tout le temps les policiers les
gendarmes il ya des trucs indéfendable
les choses comme on a vu là c'est un
manque de formation flagrant les gens
ils ont eu peur de quoi
papa de code de déontologie il faut dire
oui le poids de foot de musique en plus
je connais pas ce qu'il a fait partie de
mes élèves
voilà donc c'est n'importe quoi c'est un
gentil garçon
c'est un bébé comme toi et fais 100 kg
et il envoie des patates il met tout le
monde ko n'a pas mis un coup encore nos
cas les collègues ils ont fait n'importe
quoi
d'accord c'est impardonnable il ya des
choses que tu vois là et voilà c'est
leur faute pas leur faute
il ya un code de déontologie qui est pas
là il ya légitime défense qui est pas là
le droit n'est pas là au niveau de la
riposte n'a rien d'un comme il ya un
manque de formation qui est clair moi ça
m'a beaucoup touché
ce qu'ils ont essayé de faire me faire
passer pour un gentil flic jeu préventif
les coins alors vous pouvez le voir sur
la vidéo c'est quelqu'un que j'apprécie
beaucoup que j'aime beaucoup
il a il a quand même contribué à ma
façon de penser soir les forces de
l'ordre c'est à dire que a lancé un bon
flic quelqu'un de droit franchement je
joue aujourd'hui si si je mélange pas
tout eh ben c'est une personne qui m'a
réellement beaucoup apporté vraiment
et ce qui peut avoir aujourd'hui la
crainte quand on croise un policier la
crainte de l'uniforme
avec ce qui vous arrive et qu'on arrive
à vis la c1
moi personnellement je ne sens pas à
l'aise je me sens pas à l'aise et c'est
pas normal je vous l accorde moi je
pense que moi je pense que avec tous les
messages de policiers que que j'ai reçus
avec lui ces gendarmes
c'est là qu'ils m'ont beaucoup touché
moi je pense que c'est ces gens là qu'il
faut mettre en avant ses sept policiers
là il faut mettre en avant ce qui qui
essaie de défendre l'indéfendable
moi je n'ai temps je m'en méfie de ces
gens là sont 30 essais de défendre
quelque chose qui n'est pas défendable
je je je pense que c'est eux qui
craignent le fossé qui est entre la
population et la police d'aujourd'hui il
ya un point important aujourd'hui si on
parle vraiment de vous sait comment vous
arrivez à vous reconstruire aujourd'hui
avec tous les traumatismes qu'ont a
évoqué le psychologique physique adéquat
j'essaie de rester actif j'essaie de
rester actif je vais j'ai au studio je
joue à mes artistes
je sais que eux aussi ils voient des
fois les absents ce que j'ai je peux
dire qu'ils les comprennent mais il
l'est moi en tout cas c'est pas un
accent c1
je suis la meilleure bah je jeu des
français ça m'arrive d'avoir des petits
flashs de ce qui s'est passé c'est ça
pour me reconstruire il faut que
j'oublie faut que j'oublie les images et
comme je suis dans une procédure
quand je vais voir le jugement je
regarde les images et je les vois on les
montre quoi donc juste et sur les choses
se fassent et pour justice se fasse et
là il faut que j'assume ça je parle
beaucoup avec les jeunes d'ici et là
je chante en leur chantant les soucis
connus les mêmes par les jeunes qu'est
ce qu'ils ont vécu qu'elle pareil vous
pouvez faire entre vous et eux justement
sur le vécu des contrôles incessants
aujourd'hui reçoit même des amendes sans
être là d'ailleurs les jeunes quand ils
ont été sortis du studio amené au
commissariat
excusez ma sortie du studio battu amené
au commissariat et relâché derrière à
certains ont reçu des amendes pour non
port du masque sans avoir lu un contrôle
quelconque
moi je trouve ça bien
je suis pas sûr que la france a su ces
succès pas le même
c'est pas le regard ou c'est pas de
l'image que que que j'ai de la france en
tout cas conclut j'aimerais avoir de la
france
il ya beaucoup de choses à faire face
aujourd'hui elle est frais judiciaires
il ya aussi bien sûr et les frais
médicaux
ça fait énormément de choses à débourser
sur une période assez courte visite au
début vous n'avez pas voulu vous hésité
à lancer n4 c'était une sorte forme de
pudeur de se dire je n'ose pas y aller
je n'ose pas le faire je ne sais même
pas si je le pensais comme ça mais mais
mais naturellement je savais pas où
j'allais et comme je vous dise je
n'avais pas forcément envie de le crier
sur tous les toits
je suis fait tabasser par
trois personnes à lui un policier vous
dites habillés en policiers
rires parce que en fait je respecte
tellement les policiers que je ne veux
pas penser que c'est cesser d art de
parcours après j'entends ils ont des
bonnes notes tout ça très bien bah vous
avez vu les bus alors si on se pose de
seconde est con on regarde un peu plus
en profondeur
on va découvrir parce que moi je
rappelle que l'on bien tabassé en dames
horizon veiller à fermer la porte
je suis dans un rôle ça se passe comment
alors soit je reste là on sent et après
je me débrouille ou soit je suis en sang
et en plus de ça chemine en prison sur
le passé c'est dur le truc sur l'instant
vous êtes du mort vous avez peur de la
mort à ce moment-là sur ses longues
minutes
l'avare à la haine la haine que j'ai
ressenti sincèrement non qui se
dégageait de de lancieux ces policiers
jeux permettent un coup je vais pas me
défendre je sais pas ce qu'ils veulent
on se pose plein de questions et je leur
parle en même temps pourquoi
qu'est ce qui lie à vous tromper de
personne je dis plein de choses et puis
de manière très calme pourtant je m'en
prends ma déco rien et vous ne pas
entendre ta gueule il m'insulte non
c'est ces trois personnages ont très mal
agi et c'est pour ça que d'ailleurs que
je regarde moi les gens qu'il est qui
qui soutiennent qu'ils arrivent à
trouver à quelque chose à soutenir là
dessus même à des amis on peut ne pas
être d'accord on peut leur dire tu as
abusé
voilà l'idée même des amis pollution
n'est pas d'accord sur tout c'est des
amis pourtant on est pas d'après on
n'est pas d'accord sur tout
je vois pas pourquoi là on emploie des
mots pour pour les soigner je ne
comprends pas je moi je comprends pas
moi j'comprends pas hésité leurs rites
et et surtout je comprends pas je me
pose la question d'où sort-il heures et
était qui leur a donné
pourquoi
j'aimerais comprendre il ya l'idée aussi
de d'essayer d'en pousser quelque chose
de positif
l'idée une fondation c'est ça ça va être
quoi l'objectif c'est pas le but la
fondation l'idée m'est venue après avoir
discuté avec pas mal de jeunes de
bagneux dans un premier temps c'est un
beau lieu d'où sont originaires
j'ai vu n'était de 2,2 d'aulnay j'ai vu
ddt de la grande borne mais j'ai vu des
petits 2 de saint-denis un petit peu
partout je voudrais modestement apporter
ma petite pierre
je pense avoir les deux petites idées
pour pouvoir bouger les lignes
la théorie serait lesquelles ce comment
faire bouger aujourd'hui demain je pense
que les changes
c'est déjà un bon début peut-être même
que un policier pourrait discuter avec
un jeune il ne comprendrait et vice et
versa si on sait le dialogue les
échanges
je pense que tout près de là c'est en
tout cas moi c'est comme ça que j'arrive
comme ça qu'on échange avec nous on
discute et encore une fois on n'est pas
obligé d'être d'accord sur tout on peut
les changer
je peux le faire changer d'avis ou tu
peux me faire changer d'avis c'est comme
très loin du truc
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'on
peut vous souhaiter pour la suite
de ne pas changer je vous parlais de la
haine que j'ai eues dans les yeux de ces
de ces personnes
et ça c'est quelque chose que je
n'oublie pas en fait je vais pas oublier
que j'arrive pas à comprendre la
profondeur de cette n est certes pas la
comprendre
j'aimerais ne pas changer ce qu'on peut
me souhaiter quelque chose c'est ça
parce que quand on voit qu'on voit comme
tout ça en fait on voit comment la faire
se déroule quand on peut peut-être j'ai
devriez changer d'avis alors moi je là
je reste confiant finalement si l'on
souhaite un retour à la vie d'avant la
quiétude qui était la vôtre
mon projet à la tête bien si je pouvais
faire ça serait bien qu'au niveau nat
chez moi mais ça va être difficile de
revenir
drake a évidemment je faisais beaucoup
de sport
on va vous avez bien compris que c'est
un peu compliqué c'était vrai concept gg
tt réfléchir et sam était remplie g
parce que l'ajustement au niveau du bras
vous avez peur de ne pas réussir à
retrouver la capacité qui était la vôtre
avant j'ai il ya eu un moment où j'ai eu
peur je vous avoue et au moment où j'ai
eu très peur
et j'ai été opéré dans dans une
excellente clinique avec eux
d'excellentes chirurgien qui m'ont
assuré qu'ils m'ont assuré dessus donc
ça prendra du temps jeu je fais je fais
tout ce qu'il faut pour que je puisse me
réparer ça prendra juste du temps et
c'est vrai que là dessus sur ce point là
je suis rassuré c'est une question de
semaines de mois pour leur éducation et
magicien deux mois deux mois après ça ce
sont les choses qui joue à quoi elle
dresse et le reste c'est un petit peu
plus difficile à quantifier